scientists understand how this process
works especially well for bottlenosed
dolphins because the US Navy uses them
as soldiers well sort of as soldiers
they're mostly used to find things that
the Navy lost in the water cell phones
car keys apocalyptic nuclear warheads
sometimes these Soldier dolphins are
even sent on freshwater missions during
such missions Navy scientists have found
that noticeable skin lesions start to
develop around 12 days of freshwater
exposure this begins with a yellowing of
the skin the general blood chemistry of
a dolphin goes way out of whack
sometimes in just 24 hours so if
freshwater kills whales and dolphins how
then are there entire species of
freshwater Dolphins how does that evolve
to find out watch the full video link is
in the video
description